ARE, AFTER ALL IN THE THROES OF
THE PANDEMIC, BRET.
>> Bret: JOHN, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES BILL BARR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU, BRET.
>> Bret: THE EFFORT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, THERE IS THIS MOVEMENT
TO DEFUND THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
DEPARTMENTS.
MINNEAPOLIS CITY COUNCIL WITH A
VETO APPROVED VOTE SAYING THEY
WILL ESSENTIALLY DISMANTLE THAT
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT EFFORT
AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE
COUNTRY?
>> I THINK IT IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF THE WAY SHOULD GO.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
RASUL TO RACIAL JUSTICE IN THE
COUNTRY AND WHY THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN OR AT LEAST
SOME OF IT WOULD VIEW THE EVENTS
AS MANIFEST TO IT --
MANIFESTATIONS OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
BUT I THINK IN FACT THE PAST 50
OR 60 YEARS WE HAD A LOT OF
REFORM FROM THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
I WAS ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I CAN
TELL YOU THERE IS A WORLD OF
DIFFERENCE, TODAY THE POLICE
CHIEF UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
CHANGE AND THERE HAS BEEN GREAT
CHANGE AND I THINK DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, HOLDING THE ENTIRE
POLICE STRUCTURE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE ACTIONS OF CERTAIN OFFICERS
IS WRONG.
AND I THINK IT IS DANGEROUS TO
DEMONIZE POLICE.
>> Bret: SO HOW DO THESE BAD
COPS COME IF YOU WANT TO CALL
THEM THAT GET THROUGH IN THE
SYSTEMS?
DO YOU BLAME POLICE UNIONS?
DO YOU BLAME THE SYSTEMS
THEMSELVES FOR NOT WAITING THEM
OUT?
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS WHAT IS
FRUSTRATION AND ANGER?
>> Attorney General Barr: NOT
REFERRING TO ANY PARTICULAR CASE
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER IT IS A
NONMONOLITHIC SYSTEM.
THERE ARE 900,000 POLICE
OFFICERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND RIGHT NOW, THERE IS A CRISIS
IN POLICING BECAUSE IT IS A
TOUGH JOB.
WHAT WE HAD BEFORE COVID, FULL
COVID ECONOMY.
AND WE’VE HAD TROUBLE ATTRACTING
PEOPLE AND RETAINING PEOPLE AS
POLICE OFFICERS.
WE WANT THE BEST, MOST
RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE WE CAN GET.
WE HAVE TO ATTRACT THEM INTO THE
PROFESSION.
WE HAVE TO TRAIN THEM.
AND WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
PROFESSIONALIZE THE POLICE
FORCES.
WE HAVE GENERALLY SPEAKING
EXCELLENT POLICE FORCES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
NONE OF US AS INDIVIDUALS WANT
TO BE LUMPED TOGETHER.
WE WANT TO BE JUDGED BY WHAT WE
DO AS INDIVIDUALS.
WE DON’T WANT MISCONDUCT OF
OTHERS ATTRIBUTED TO US.
THAT IS IN EVERY WALK OF LIFE.
ONE OF THE LEGITIMATE GRIEVANCES
OF THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, THEY ARE TREATED WITH
SUSPICION AND EMBRACED AS
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THAT DOES HAPPEN.
BY THE SAME TOKEN, PEACEFUL
WOMEN’S TRADER SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED AS VIOLENT EXTREMIST
BECAUSE SIMPLY OUT ON THE
STREETS.
THAT IS THE SAME WITH POLICE
OFFICERS.
EVERY ORGANIZATION HAS
INDIVIDUALS ENGAGING IN THIS
CONDUCT, AND WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL BEFORE WE SAY ALL
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Bret: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
A MAJOR AMERICAN CITY, CHICAGO,
D.C. DISBAND ITS POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE?
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
TO STEP DOWN?
>> Attorney General Barr: WHAT
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE IS
VENTILATED -- VENTILATED IN
SHIISM AND CHAOS IN THE CITY.
AND THAT IS WHY DOING THINGS
THAT PREVENT US FROM HAVING A
STRONG EFFECT OF POLICE FORCE
ARE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
YOU HAVE MORE KILLINGS.
THAT’S BEEN SHOWN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
>> Bret: A MAJOR AMERICAN CITY
DOING THAT WOULD BE DANGEROUS.
>> Attorney General Barr:
ABSOLUTELY, WE HAVE TO PUT
THINGS IN PERSPECTIVE,
OBVIOUSLY.
WHEN POLICE USE EXCESSIVE FORCE
THEY HAVE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ZOOMED IN AND IMMEDIATELY TOOK
UP THE MATTER.
THERE IS NO QUESTION IT IS AN
ISSUE AND HAS TO BE DEALT WITH
PATENT TERMS OF SHEER NUMBERS,
THE POLICE OFFICERS WHO ARE
PRESSING AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE A LOT MORE DAMAGE FROM
A LOT MORE KILLING COME A LOT
MORE FEAR IN GENERAL ON THE
STREETS FROM CRIMINAL ELEMENTS.
FOR CHICAGO, FOR EXAMPLE 50
PEOPLE SHOT.
IF YOU PULLED BACK THE POLICE
FROM THESE COMMUNITIES, THEY
WILL BE MORE HARM DONE TO THE
COMMUNITIES.
THE PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW HAS BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM ISSUE.
HE TOOK THE FIRST STEP ACT AND
SET UP THE POLICE SINCE
LYNDON JOHNSON AND LOOKING FOR
SITES WITH THESE ISSUES AND
COMING OUT SHORTLY BUT THE
PROPOSALS ON THIS.
AND HE’S ALSO ADVANCED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES IN THE
INNER-CITY.
HE’S PUSHING FOR SCHOOL CHOICE
FOR INNER-CITY PARENTS THAT TO
ME AS A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF
THE ERA IS GIVING THE PARENTS
THE WHEREWITHAL TO EDUCATE THEIR
CHILDREN IN THE BEST SCHOOLS
POSSIBLE.
HE IS ADDRESSING THAT.
PULLING THE POLICE BACK FROM
THESE COMMUNITIES WOULD MAKE IT
FAR MORE DIFFICULT FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND FULL
PARTICIPATION IN THE AMERICAN
DREAM THEY DESERVE.
>> Bret: AS YOU KNOW, THERE IS
A HOUSE BILL AND EFFORT FOR
POLICE REPORT FORM FROM CONGRESS
WHICH INCLUDES A FEW THINGS.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
AND NATIONAL MISCONDUCT REGISTRY
FOR THE POLICE.
>> Attorney General Barr: I
HAVEN’T LOOKED AT THE PROPOSAL,
SO I’M NOT EXACTLY SURE.
ON THE ISSUES OF THOSE BUT ISSUE
BY ISSUE, THERE IS A PRUDENT
BALANCE TO BE STRUCK BETWEEN
MAKING SURE, ACCOUNTABLE.
POLICE IS NOT LIKE SITTING IN AN
OFFICE.
WE PUT THESE INDIVIDUALS INTO A
HIGHLY CHARGED, DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS WHERE THEIR OWN LIFE
IS AT STAKE.
THEY DRILL IN ADRENALINE IS
PUMPING AND SO FORTH.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE TREAT
THEM FAIRLY IN THOSE TIMES OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Bret: PANNING CHOKE HOLD?
>> Attorney General Barr: I
THINK WE SHOULD BAN LATERAL
CHOKE HOLDS EXCEPT WHEN
NECESSARY TO MEET LETHAL -- AND
LIST POLICE ARE CONFRONTED WITH
POTENTIAL LETHAL FORCE.
I THINK THERE IS A GENERAL
AGREEMENT AMONG POLICE AGENCIES
WE NEED CLEARER STANDARDS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THOSE
STANDARDS ARE CLAIMED TO WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE SYSTEMS
IN PLACE TO HOLD OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE.
I THINK THERE IS UNIVERSAL
AGREEMENT ON THAT.
>> Bret: IS THAT A FEDERAL
EFFORT?
A FEDERAL TRAINING EFFORTS?
>> Attorney General Barr: I
THINK WE NEED A FEDERAL, STRONG
PARTICIPATION IN THE EFFORT TO
SET STANDARDS.
>> Bret: A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
MONDAY RELIVING THE MOMENT AT
LAFAYETTE PARK.
IF YOU HAD TO DO MONDAY OVER
AGAIN, WOULD YOU DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT?
>> Attorney General Barr:
BASED ON WHAT I KNOW NOW, NO.
MONDAY, WE WERE REACTING TO
THREE DAYS OF EXTREMELY VIOLENT
DEMONSTRATIONS.
RIGHT ACROSS FROM A LOT OF
INJURIES TO THE POLICE OFFICERS,
ARSON.
THINGS WERE SO BAD THE
SECRET SERVICE SECRET SERVICE
RECOMMENDED DOWN IN THE BUNKER
AND WE CAN’T HAVE THAT IN OUR
PUNKER SO THE DECISION WAS MADE.
WE HAD TO MOVE THE PERIMETER ONE
BLOCK AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
>> Bret: DID THE PRESIDENT
TELL YOU HE WAS PLANNING ON
WALKING OVER TO THE CHURCH?
>> AG Barr: HE DIDN’T TELL ME.
I FOUND OUT LATER IN THE
AFTERNOON HE MIGHT GO OUTSIDE OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT LIKE I SAID THE DECISION TO
MOVE OUTSIDE OF THE PERIMETER
WAS MADE SUNDAY NIGHT BY THE
PARK POLICE IN THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS.
ON MONDAY WHEN I ARRIVED, I
AGREED WITH THE GENERAL OF
CONCEPTION TO MOVE THE
PARAMETERS TO FORTIFY A SENSE OF
A STRONGER FENCING AND SO FORTH,
LAFAYETTE PARK, AND ALSO GIVE
SOME BREATHING SPACE.
IN THAT DECISION WAS SETTING AND
EXECUTION AT 2:00 WITH ALL THE
POLICE TACTICAL CHIEFS.
>> Bret: BUT I MEAN SEEING
WHAT HAS COME FROM IT IN THE
IMAGE THAT HAS AT LEAST BEEN
PERCEIVED, YOU WOULDN’T DO IT
DIFFERENT?
>> AG Barr: THE IMAGE HAS
SOMEWHAT BEEN CREATED AND
MISCREATED IN A SENSE THAT I
HAVEN’T SEEN ANY VIDEOS ON TV OF
ALL THE VIOLENCE THAT WAS
HAPPENING PRECEDING THAT.
>> Bret: YOU WERE HIT OR
SOMETHING WAS THROWN AT YOU?
>> AG Barr: I DID GO TO THE
PARK BEFORE THE ACTUAL OPERATION
TO MOVE OUT THE PERIMETER.
I PERSONALLY SAW PROJECTILES
THROWN AND TWO WERE THROWN AT
ME.
THE POLICE OFFICERS THERE IN MY
SECURITY DETAIL MADE ME MOVE
BACK BECAUSE THEY SAID THE
PROJECTILES HAD BEEN LANDING,
THINGS LIKE ROCKS, BOTTLES.
>> Bret: YOU SAID YOU WOULDN’T
DO ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY, BUT THE
PERCEPTION OF CLEARING OUT THE
PARK, UNDERSTANDING YOU MADE THE
DECISION EARLIER AND THE
PRESIDENT WALKING OVER, EVEN THE
VISUAL OF THE GROUP ALL WHITE,
MOSTLY MALE, IT SENT AN IMAGE A
LOT OF PEOPLE JUMPED ON.
AND SAID IT WASN’T A GOOD THING
FOR THE PRESIDENT IN RETROSPECT.
I ASKED YOU, WOULD YOU DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY?
WOULD YOU DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENTLY EVEN THE WALK OVER
TO THE CHURCH?
YOU WERE THERE IN THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY AND SO WAS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS.
>> AG Barr: YOU KNOW, IT’S
NOT -- THAT WAS A DECISION FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE.
MY DECISION THAT YOU ASKED ME
ABOUT EARLIER WAS MOVING THE
PERIMETER ONE BLOCK TO PROVIDE
GREATER SECURITY FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I WOULD DO THE SAME.
I DON’T SAY THIS AS A CRITIC OF
THESE KINDS OF LEADERSHIP
DECISIONS MADE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, BUT AS I HAVE SAID,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
WALK ONE BLOCK FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE OUT TO THE CHURCH.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND THIS CANARD THAT THIS
EXERCISE WAS DONE TO MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE IS TOTALLY FALSE.
I DON’T SEE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
THE PRESIDENT WALKING OVER TO
THE CHURCH.
>> Bret: THE PERCEPTION IS THE
PRESIDENT WAS CALLING FOR I
DON’T KNOW HOW MANY, 10,000, BUT
LET’S JUST SAY THOUSANDS OF
ACTIVE MILITARY TROOPS ON THE
GROUND.
DID YOU PUSH BACK ON THE USE OF
THE INSURRECTION ACT?
>> AG Barr: THERE WAS NO NEED
TO PUSH BACK.
I THINK EVERYONE WAS ON THE SAME
PAGE.
WHAT WE WERE DISCUSSING IS WHAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND D.C. SPECIFICALLY.
AND I THINK EVERYONE AGREED THAT
IF IT BECAME NECESSARY, WE COULD
RESORT TO FEDERAL TROOPS AS A
LAST RESORT.
>> Bret: THERE’S A LOT OF
PEOPLE CHARGED WITH CRIMES
EVOLVED INTO RIOTS AND LOOTING.
TO MY KNOWLEDGE, NONE OF THE
CRIMINAL COMPLAINTS MENTIONED
ANTIFA.
WHY IS THAT?
>> AG Barr: WE HAVE SOME
INVESTIGATIONS UNDERWAY AND VERY
UNFOCUSED INVESTIGATIONS ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT LEAD TO
ANTI-PIT.
THE INITIAL PHASE OF IDENTIFYING
PEOPLE AND ARRESTING THEM, THEY
WERE ARRESTED FOR CRIMES THAT
DON’T REQUIRE US TO IDENTIFY A
PARTICULAR GROUP.
>> Bret: DOES ANTIFA HAVE
LEADERS?
>> AG Barr: IT IS A LOOSELY
ORGANIZED GROUP AND HAVE AN
ELITE OR UNUSUAL SYSTEM OF
COMMUNICATION AND ORGANIZATION.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT CAN BE
CHARACTERIZED AS LEADERS IN ANY
GIVEN SITUATION.
>> Bret: ARE THERE PEOPLE
FINDING THIS EFFORT, AND
ORGANIZED EFFORT THAT GOES
BEYOND DATE SPECIFIC, FUNDING
THE EFFORT BROADLY, AND ARE YOU
GOING AFTER THOSE PEOPLE?
>> AG Barr: THERE APPEAR TO BE
SOURCES OF FUNDING AND WE ARE
LOOKING INTO THE SOURCES OF
FUNDING.
AND CLEARLY, A HIGH DEGREE OF
ORGANIZATION INVOLVED AT SOME OF
THESE EVENTS AND COORDINATED
TACTICS AND WE ARE LOOKING INTO
THAT AS WELL.
SOME OF THAT RELATES TO ANTIFA.
SOME RELATES TO GROUPS THAT ACT
VERY MUCH LIKE ANTIFA.
AS I SAID, THERE IS A WITCHES
BREW OF EXTREMIST GROUP TO
EXPLOIT THE SITUATION ON ALL
SIDES.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT
COVID-19 AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED,
DO YOU THINK WE WILL CONCLUDE
THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS WENT TOO
FAR TO SHUT DOWN SOCIETY TO THE
POINT OF TRAMPLING AMERICANS
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS?
>> AG Barr: I THINK GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY INVOLVED IN A VERY
FAST PACE ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN
AREAS, THE ORIGINAL 30 DAY OR SO
AND EVEN WITH EXTENSIONS
MEASURES WERE APPROPRIATE, BUT I
THINK THAT AS TIME HAS GONE BY,
THE DEBRIS OF IMPINGEMENT ON
FUNDAMENTAL LIBERTIES HAS NEVER
BEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
NATIONALLY PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM ENGAGING IN THEIR
LIVELIHOOD, TELLING THEM TO STAY
HOME IS SORT OF A FORM OF HOUSE
ARREST IN MANY PLACES.
>> Bret: HAVE THESE PROTESTS
AND DEMONSTRATIONS AND WHAT WAS
SEEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY CHANGE
THAT DYNAMIC?
>> AG Barr: I THINK IT SHOULD
BECAUSE IT RAISES A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION WHICH IS, WHY SHOULD
SOME PEOPLE ENJOYING THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS BY GOING
OUT AND PROTESTING HAVE BROADER
RIGHTS THAN OTHER PEOPLE WHO MAY
WANT TO EXERCISE, FOR EXAMPLE
THEIR RELIGIOUS FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AND GO TO CHURCH.
AS LONG AS SOCIAL DISTANCING
RULES ARE COMPLIED WITH.
>> Bret: THERE WAS A REPORT
THE U.S. DEMAND WRITTEN HANDOVER
PRINCE ANDREW TO BE QUESTION AT
LENGTH ABOUT THE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> AG Barr: I DON’T THINK IT
IS A QUESTION OF HANDING HIM
OVER BUT JUST HAVE HIM PROVIDE
SOME EVIDENCE.
BUT BEYOND THAT, I WILL NOT
COMMENT.
>> Bret: SO EXTRADITION?
>> AG Barr: NO.
>> Bret: JUST ASKING FOR
EVIDENCE.
THAT CASE IS STILL IN PROCESS.
YOU COMMENTED ON THE DEATH OF
EPSTEIN AND YORK CONVINCED HE
COMMITTED SUICIDE.
IS THERE MORE TO COME FROM THAT
INVESTIGATION?
>> AG Barr: THERE MIGHT BE
MORE TO COME BUT I DON’T THINK
ANYTHING WILL CHANGE THAT
CONCLUSION.
>> Bret: WHAT IS YOUR
DEFINITION OF LAW AND ORDER.
>> AG Barr: THE REAL TEST TO
FRAME THE GOVERNMENT IS TO HAVE
A GOVERNMENT THAT IS CAPABLE OF
GOVERNING, STRONG ENOUGH TO
GOVERN, BUT NOT SO STRONG THAT
IT ABRIDGES THE RIGHTS OF THE
PEOPLE.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE POWER,
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
CONTROL ON THE POWER.
IN THE CASE OF THE GOVERNMENT,
FOR EXAMPLE, EXCESSIVE POLICE
FORCE, LAW AND ORDER MEANS THE
GOVERNMENT IS BOUND BY LAW AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ABUSING THEIR POWER.
>> Bret: THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED
TO HAVE A PANDEMIC WITH
LOCKDOWNS AND THEN THIS, THAT
WITH PROTESTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
>> AG Barr: THAT IS RIGHT.
THE LAST TIME I WAS AG, I WAS A
DEPUTY BEFORE THAT AND SOMEONE
SHOWED ME A LIST OF ALL THE
CRISES WE HANDLED AT THAT TIME.